which one makes me look more like a
Harvard man I'm thrilled to report that
you look nothing like a Harvard man came
in welcome to Harvard Law School
I miss phaedra Ginsburg and why are you
here miss Ginsburg occupying a place
that could have gone to a man you're the
smartest person here so just say well
you know mr. Fitzpatrick
last week I was told women are too
emotional to be lawyers you're cheb
Chris one interviewer told me they hired
a woman last year and what in the world
would they want with two of us you're
angry good news there are hundred and
seventy-eight loss a different shape on
the basis of sex our laws that say women
can't work overtime to get credit card
our husband's not a lots of women whose
we're not allowed to work in mind how
would you want to what's not the point
we should be allowed
I'm gonna convince the courts that those
laws are unconstitutional
I don't read tax court cases
read this one the law assumes a
caregiver has to be a woman
this is sex-based discrimination against
a man so judge was wrong mr. Mart's the
law is wrong they think gender equality
is a civil right you must see the
opportunity this case represents men and
women both of you will lose
Routh's and when you do you will set the
woman's moving back 10 years you don't
get to tell me when to quit
we should look to her generation they
take him to the streets demanding change
you would do well to remember this is a
privilege it is not a privilege it is a
cage and these laws are the bar
every dipping
you're ready for this you've been ready
for this your whole life we all must
take these laws on one by one to topple
the whole damn system of discrimination
the word woman does not appear even once
in the US Constitution notice the word
freedom your honor
[Music]